20 صاروخا من اصل 43 اطلقت على خمس
مقاطعات اليوم اسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه
فوق قياف القوات الاوكرانيه لكن شظايا هذه
الصواريخ اصابت
منشات مدنيه وتحديدا بعض الابنيه
والمنشات الصناعيه في احد احياء العاصمه
هناك احياء اخرى اصيبت جراء شظايا التي
تساقطت في اماكن مختلفه هذا هو احد
الامكنه التي اصيب فيه عدد من المواطنين
الشرطه
فرضت حظرا على بعض
الصور في المنشاه صناعيه هنا وفي حفره
احدثها وقوع شظايا صاروخ كبيره الحجم
وطلبت الشرطه عدم التصوير في هذه المنطقه
وهذه الاضرار في احد المباني السكنيه وفرق
الطوارئ واللغات التي تعمل على ازاله
الركام وهي بدات بازالته من داخل المنازل
وان الى محيطه
السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان هناك اضرار
في بعض المقاطعات الغربيه وتحديدا في خطوط
الكهرباء التي اصيبت بجراء الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه التي اطلقت على عدد من
المقاطعات الغربيه هناك منشاه صناعيه في
ليفيف ومنشاه تخزين اصيبت
بصاروخين وفق الاداره العسكريه ايضا في
شرك شركسي وهي مقاطعه تقع جنوب العاصمه
وهو فندق وجرى اخراج كل الذين بداخله 10
منهم اصيبوا بجروح بعضهم اصابتهم بليغه
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت قالت ان 43 صاروخا
من نوع كروز اطلقت على مناطق مختلفه من
اوكرانيا
سبعه وثلاثون جرى اسقاطها في مناطق مختلفه
من اوكرانيا وفق ما اعلنت قياده الاركان
القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا هناك هجمات اخرى
على طول خطوط الاشتباك لكن القوات
الاوكرانيه تريد تثبيت ان دفاعاتها الجويه
لازالت تعمل بفعاليه وان هذه الدفاعات
قادره على التصدي لمعظم الهجمات بالصواريخ
او بالمسيرات الروسيه التي تطلق باستمرار
باتجاه اهداف مختلفه في المدن الاوكرانيه
لذلك فان اوكرانيا تركز على اهميه
الدفاعات الجويه في هذه المرحله وتطلب من
شركائها الغربيين بتزويدها المزيد منها
للدفاع عن المدن الرئيسيه والمنشات
الضروريه في هذه المرحله وتحديدا تلك التي
ترتبط بتامين التدفئه للمواطنين الاوكران
في فصل الشتاء لذلك فالقوات الاوكرانيه
تطلب ايضا دفاعات لتامين خط ما يعرف بخط
القمح الذي فتحته من اوديسا باتجاه موانئ
مختلفه حول العالم